are you shooting now coming to America
sequel we already finished you finished
it venison I I can't you know coming to
America is one of my favorite movies
it's all body's favorite movie - I hear
that all the time and in a way and I
love Eddie Murphy and Arsenio was
fabulous and the whole thing was just
perfect movie you know in a way I'm even
shocked they're making a sequel if I
would say Demark I'd be afraid to touch
that thing and I'm gonna tell you I I
was afraid to touch it also but I'm
gonna tell you right now when Eddie
Murphy walked on set
dressed as a king everybody got chills
cuz it was almost like it was a
continuation of the movie it literally
felt like the movie had just came out
last year
really it was everybody on set said the
same thing like oh this is gonna be big
do you pinch yourself you're on the set
with Eddie Murphy in the sequel to
coming to America yeah I guess I pinched
myself I think I'm more of like I'll be
over it as soon as I get it I know
nerves I always hear nerves you want to
do well in front of Eddie yeah yeah but
I already knew Eddie so and I knew that
he likes me and how'd you know Eddie
actually I met Eddie long time way
before esterday when you was just
starting like doing comedy just like I
was hardcore doing time like where Jamie
Foxx was when I first saw him yes is
where I was when Eddie Murphy saw me I
was at the Laugh Factory nice um did he
give you some sort of feedback well the
time yeah at the time he was married to
Nicole his first wife and he left out
the side and had them bring me over and
he was like oh my god we love you we
think you're so funny
we watch you on be et all the time and I
was like bTW I guess it's kind of great
to be able to meet in any Murphy and ask
him hey maybe some rice or something
well it's also great that they're going
hey you're funny
like you feel like okay I'm on the right
I'm on the right path